okay
you know I'm slow
glory to Ukraine glory to the heroes
KY
um
so Mr President zielinski we welcome
especially very symbolic Nations
foreign
as soon as possible please the floor is
yours
thank you so much for the important
words of support thank you so much
Japanese people
um
uh
of Destruction
instead of the normal life
foreign
[Music]
they had buried
University
National
foreign
glory to Ukraine
okay
synonyms right
[Music]
James Bays from Al Jazeera Mr President
there were some confusion about your
comments on Bak mood so can I ask you to
clarify the situation in bakward is the
battle for the city still ongoing and
the difficult part of my question was
the defense of bakmut worth all the
effort and most importantly all the
lives that have been lost
thank you for the question
we don't have simple questions anymore
as well as we don't have simple answers
because we have a very complicated
neighbor who is a criminal a terrorist a
complicated
we are fighting thanks to the courage of
our people our Warriors
could happen
foreign
let me remind you once again uh we are
taking questions not by raising hands
but by standing up to microphones to the
left and to the right from the hall and
the second question is from uh the voice
of America Ukraine
thank you Mr President uh Michigan White
House correspondent I'm going to switch
to Ukrainian if you don't mind
thank you thank you for the question yes
well really
for a long time
of the strengthening of our skies
besides defense for that we are really
grateful to the United States of America
as the leaders as for the support in
this year
foreign
Mackenzie gray with global news from
Canada today you met with Justin Trudeau
our prime minister uh he didn't announce
any new weapons or Aid are you satisfied
with the support that Canada has been
giving to Ukraine in the last number of
months
thank you
I would like you to understand
we have powerful relations with Canada
there are some of the points which may
be publicly cannot be commented so far
we don't have anything to make public we
are working on something but Canada is
supporting us we are speaking today with
a powerful block of the mining equipment
you know this is about the hundreds of
thousands of square kilometers because
Russia is not just an enemy they are
acting not like an enemy but as a
terrorist they mind our Fields these are
really hundreds of thousands of square
kilometers
of one country wouldn't be sufficient
enough that is why we are saying that
Canada supported us with this package
now we have the beginning of the
delivery of a certain equipment from
Canadian side it has already taken place
Bloomberg right yes thank you uh Mr
President Rosalind Matheson from
Bloomberg in London I wanted to ask you
you've met many leaders here uh while
you've been at the G7 but one leader
you're not seeing is the Brazilian
president Lula I wanted to know why
that's not happening and the reason I'm
asking is because Russia is the
aggressor in this war as you said you
hope that they are the last aggressors
and yet even some of the leaders here it
seems don't see that as clearly as you
do and why is that and how can we do
more to stop countries like Brazil India
and China sending sources of Hard Cash
to Russia thank you
evidence that Brazil China or India are
sending any questions to Russia though I
will be pranked with you I was in touch
with certain leaders not to have any
steps from their side and this is the
first point secondly it's so important
for us to be United together to get
together this is a very important sign
and a step and that is very important
for us as the task to involve everyone
in the peace formula which is based on
our experience and our proposals which I
have presented at GG 20 Summit in
Indonesia
sometime past we were working very well
and today we need to involve as many
countries as possible for the first
founding Summit I think it would be a
very important political pressure onto
aggressor
so I think that that is why we couldn't
meet with
the Brazilian president I'm sorry are
you disappointed that you couldn't get
time with Lula
is it disappointing for you
I think it disappointed him
uh
thank you the next question in the back
huh
is
um as
we understand that you're asking about
the weapons but not all of the people in
Japan especially here in Hiroshima
supporting this idea maybe you should
speak more in Hiroshima about
negotiations for peace
so let me tell you
[Music]
and what we can see today
which were mentioned
I am from domestic media called MBS I
would like to ask you you've just
visited atomic bomb Museum in this
evening right next to this building was
there any specific expression that still
stay in your mind or in your memory that
you want to share when you go back to
Ukraine and also uh what is nuclear
means you right now
thank you for the question
well you know
it is really
there are lots of tragic pictures in the
museum the children
little babies
before their demise before their death
and we have similar pictures
unfortunately only tears are in my eyes
this is just a tragedy how the people
are capable to do something like that
especially with the children how can you
do that to the children honestly you
don't understand I don't have for that
diagnosis I cannot understand this
disease that is why I I'm not a doctor
to understand the secrets Russians are
having such attitude towards us and the
tragedy from your pictures all of that
is really very similar
in my speech I was thinking about the
shadow I said that's not in vain because
I could see the picture where there was
only a shadow left of a human being who
was just sitting and nothing was left
but this is my impression
the microphone to the right in the rare
please
Mrs zelinski I'm Tessa Wong from BBC
News I have three questions for you I
hope you don't mind me asking you number
one is what kind of weapons deals have
you secured at the G7 Summit and who
gave you what number two is how
confident will you get your f-16s since
no countries have promised them to you
yet
number three is when will your counter
offensive happen what conditions need to
be fulfilled before you decide to launch
it
yeah I'm not sure I will answer the
three questions
first of all which weapons
so it's for the first question yeah
yeah I'm I'm sorry I'm a little bit
tired yeah the first was about the
weapon yes the first is what kind of
weapons deals have you secured at the G7
Summit from the people that you have met
and who will give you what
the weapons of high quality it will be
provided by everyone
how confident will you get your f-16s
since no con since no countries have
problems
we will be working on that I'm sure
because we already have the
understanding which states
we have been working before
mechanisms
I would like to mention some of that but
so far because we just don't have it yes
the question is
I do apologize all of your questions are
of such a character such a nature that I
need to answer in a very common
Russian will feel when we'll have a
counter-reference
the question from the left please thank
you Mr President Hugh Remington from
Channel 10 in Australia you met two
leaders of major democratic nations or
not members of the G7 India and
Australia can you tell us what you got
what you felt you got from your
conversations with Mr Modi and Mr
albanizi of Australia has said that he
does a rule out offering more support to
Ukraine but wants to do so in
negotiations with your government did
you have any discussions about anything
new that Australia might do
respectful as of Australia India the
countries which do not belong to G7 for
us the most important
I cannot afford myself accidental
meetings because we are at War I don't
have time for that really so we were in
Saudi Arabia before we are waiting to
involve the maximum amount of countries
number of countries absolutely with
totally different continents to involve
all of them into diplomatic pressure to
Russia through Terrace foreign
thank you very much for your speech my
name is Kathleen minoza and I'm from the
Japan times so my first question would
be with your surprise visit all eyes are
now in Ukraine and some say this takes
attention away from Hiroshima and
nuclear disarmament what do you think
about that
to the right please president thank you
so much for taking our questions I'm
motoko rich with the New York Times you
mentioned diplomatic pressure but given
the inefficacy of this diplomatic
pressure so far on Russia do you want
countries like Japan our host today and
South Korea to actually send lethal
weapons to support the war in Ukraine
thank you for the question
um
[Music]
which is taking place the most important
to have the respect Russia
[Music]
so that is
but I understand that there are certain
yeah
legislative or constitutional
complications
to the left your question please
thank you Mr President for your
visitation in Ukraine what are you
expecting most of all from Japan in the
future
we had two meetings
thank you
so much
thank you so much goodbye